[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alan iverson set to join us hall of
famer member of the 75th anniversary
team joins us on behalf of points bet
the uh provides the deepest slate of
pregame and in uh play betting options
in the world he's been an ambassador
since the brand's launch in 2019. we'll
talk about your tattoos coming up in a
moment but uh thanks for joining us aye
it's been a while uh what do you miss
most football or basketball
oh man um
it's been um
i don't know i got a chance to
you know really play basketball the way
i wanted to so
um
i would say football definitely
but what do you miss like i think you've
said you would have been a better
football player than basketball player
why do you feel that way
first of all it was just my first love
um it was the first game that uh i fell
in love with
um
and i just feel like um
my versatility you know what i mean
being able to play so many different
positions
um
and having
you know i think
more of an impact on the game because i
was able to play on both sides of the
ball
i wonder if you were born like 15 years
too soon like if you were if you were
coming up now
do you think you would stay with
football
or try to do both
i would i would definitely try to do
both um
you know just
you know from the
love that i have for basketball and that
i've had with basketball since um
michael jordan gave me the vision
um
i definitely would have tried to play
both um
and i you know i i really put in that
effort because when i went to georgetown
i asked um you know coach thompson could
i play
um football because you know we had to
walk to the gym
um every day from class and i always had
to pass the football field and i
remember going past the football field i
used to always get emotional and tears
would be you know coming out of my eyes
and um you know because i missed the
game so much and one day i just built up
enough courage to ask him could i play
and i don't think i can um with the
language i don't think i can say
but i never thought about playing again
but but it made you that emotional
yeah yeah i mean cause i loved it so
much i mean it was it was such a big
part of my life
um
and um you know just the the the fact of
um how effective i was at it and and i
was getting better and better at it and
then when the situation happened um with
the bowling alley and um you know when i
uh obviously i got in that trouble and
um when i came home you know i was
recruited by everybody in the country um
in both sports and um i had no more
offers at all and my mom eventually went
up to georgetown and begged my life and
coach gave me a shot in the rest is
history
if you didn't get into trouble where do
you think you would have gone instead of
georgetown i thought about i really
wanted to go to notre dame um
i wanted to go to notre dame
and then uh joe smith went to maryland
so i thought about maryland to play with
him
um and then i i went up to
duke on and not really a visit but i you
know went up there and
and um i got to meet bobby hurley bobby
hurley was my favorite
um college basketball player really you
know
yes so i really wanted to go there
because i i love bobby early so much
wait were you rooting for duke against
unlv
i never no
no um
i wasn't the duke fan i was a bobby
hurley fan
what was it about hurley that you liked
his toughness i just love how tough he
was um the small statue i'll tell you
something um crazy dan like when when uh
i got to the lead i played against him
one time and i remember his dad being on
the sideline and
once again you know about his language
so you know i just remember him telling
um
you know telling bobby to bust my ass
and uh and some more stuff that went
along with it and i was like hey like
don't even know you know how much i love
bobby hurley
obviously he didn't but um yeah man i i
never was a
um a duke fan i was definitely a
bobby hurley fan though how did you
react or what did you think when michael
jordan referred to you as a little bit
or
did first time he saw you didn't he used
that expression
it was i don't think that was the first
time he saw me we was at the um we was
at the
um
the all-star game uh the year that
without that had to be my rookie year it
was um
the year that they gave out they was uh
they did the top 50. yeah um guys yeah
and um and i was i think i was coming
off the court from something and i saw
him and they were getting ready to go on
because he had his jacket on and he just
grabbed me it's a photo out there with
him having me like in a headlock and he
was just like you know what's up
but no there was no disrespect in it and
then i didn't take it that way anyway i
was just happy for him just saying
anything to me
but but when you see yourself cross over
mike twice
like pretty impressive
like what do you think
i mean it was it was um
it was against you know it was against
black jesus and i always i always told
my friends growing up you know that um
if i ever got an opportunity to try my
move on the best that ever played the
game that i would
and um
you know was just a moment it just
happened and you know i bagged them up
and i did it i really didn't know the
significance of it when it first
happened um because i was just into the
game just playing the game but then in
the aftermath of everything and seeing
it all on espn and you know all on the
news and everybody talk about it i was
like oh
yeah you know i i really um
i really did something but you know
thinking back on it um i had got guys
way worse than that but it was just the
fact that it was him you know what i
mean and the crazy part about it is he
still almost blocked it i know i know
of how tough he was and how great he was
but he didn't say anything to you did he
after you did it
nah um he didn't say nothing to me um
um until years later i went to uh
because i live in charlotte so i went to
a hornets game
and uh
you know me and him were i i guess it
was an area in the back where you know
he chilled at at halftime
and he had me back there and we were
just talking and i just kept telling him
how much i loved him and and how much he
meant to my life and in my career
and um you know telling him i wouldn't
have had that vision of playing
basketball if it wasn't for him and he
was like you don't love me that much you
wouldn't cross me like that
laughing
we laughed about it what's crazy with
him is i get around and i've been around
him so many times you know since the
first time i met him and i still get
like nervous i still you know just
just fidgety around him all the time you
know because i love him so much and you
know he's still like when i see him you
know he don't look real he's like he got
a some of
a glow about him or something
or
you know what i mean just don't seem
he's the only person in my life that
i've ever met and he don't look human to
me
but there has to be these younger
players that look up to you the way you
looked up to jordan that's one of the
greatest feelings in the world you know
especially with me being here with my um
all-american game you know with my
classic and you know the way they look
at me the way i have their attention
when i'm talking and um it's just it
kind of it
it makes me feel like
okay this how you was you know or this
how you are with him and it's just a
great feeling to see that you know guys
grew up off of me and um you know love
me the way i the way i love him you know
it's just it's just a blessing alan can
you hold on i got a few more questions i
want to ask including
the famous press conference when you
said we're talking about practice
we're back with allen iverson here on
the dan patrick show right after this
we talked football we talked michael
jordan talked about a variety of things
with ellen iverson kind enough to stay
with us here for a few more minutes
joining us on behalf of points bet which
prides itself on speed and ease uh the
ease of using it the deepest slate of
pregame and in play betting options in
the world and he's been an ambassador
since uh the brand's launch in 2019 alan
iverson rejoins us so what are you doing
with uh points bet
um
anything to ask me to do
[Laughter]
definitely you know i mean we have a
great relationship it's been a couple
years now um
and it's just a great partnership um i
don't do a whole lot of betting on games
my my you know my friends do that you
know they're into it they they do it
damn near every day
and um i just do they ask you for advice
though
no
no
no they just use me for
for who i am they use you for tickets
and things like that
i mean just like everybody else dude
i'm surprised that this many this many
years later after playing that i'm still
um
irrelevant and popular well you were
here
yes i'm right i must have did something
right out there but but you know you're
an iconic figure it's almost like randy
moss in football
like like you were ahead of your time
that's a great compliment by the way
yeah
but you you know when you had the
tattoos and how people viewed you and
now everybody's got tattoos
but at the time
did you feel like you were kind of on an
island that it was just yes yes yes
that's a great question and um
um
because i i kind of i kind of
i kind of took the ass with before dan
you know what i mean
and it's kind of bittersweet because
back then i was so young was 21 years
old and i didn't understand i was
basically just dressing like the guys
from
you know my neighborhood that i you know
grew up with you know so it was natural
to me and then with the tattoos
it was basically like um
you know i always wanted them but i just
couldn't afford them and then once i
you know could afford them then that's
why i just went overboard with it you
know because
you know every all my tattoos mean
something and then
with the hair like i was would go on the
road and guys would mess my hair up when
i go to the barber shop so i always i
thought like man if i could just get it
cornrowed then i don't have to worry
about you know guys messing my hair up
on the road so that's how that happened
you know what i mean so
you know with the dress code and all
that you know i i was hurt by it i
didn't understand it or whatever and you
know now you see guys wearing whatever
they want and and and you know looking
the way they want and you know i i know
it's had a lot to do with me you know
getting the dress code um changed but
you know it's a good feeling now to see
you guys express themselves the way they
you know want to because when you look
at the game everybody don't play the
same so why would everybody you know
look the same why would everybody dress
the same you got all these guys in suits
when i grew up i never went to the park
with a suit on to play basketball
so
the only time that i wore suits was to
church and to a funeral so you know
david stern said everybody thinks this
is the allen iverson rule he said
it's really steve nash that he had a
problem with how steve nash dressed when
he went to the press conference as well
so just to let you know that's that's
the commissioner telling me because i i
referenced the allen iverson dress code
he goes
uh steve nash uh i had a problem with
how steve nash dressed at press
conferences
learned something new every day i did
not know that yeah you know and and
god bless him i mean me and him became
so close you know what i mean um
especially after my career was over you
know what i mean the latter part of my
career and towards the end you know what
i mean i i got a you know great
relationship with him and i'm glad you
know that it ended up being that way
before he passed me rest in peace what's
your best tattoo
uh
my kids look at the kids
you didn't get a michael jordan tattoo
no i was never i was not i love him
if you had money
when you're growing up would you have
gotten to michael jordan today when i
maybe maybe when i was a i would think
yeah maybe when i was a little kid yeah
you know what i mean but i i i knew that
that would probably be something
super corny i wouldn't i wouldn't do
that but not that much
uh what do you see when you see john
morant
i see um greatness
i see greatness i see um
a once-in-a-lifetime talent
um
i see
a lot of myself in him as far as the um
fearlessness
um
him being a competitor him just being a
killer that could um
that could um
change the game in so many ways
um
i see uh
someone um
that you know his teammates love
and they
and they follow and they believe in i
think
you know when i
thinking about him
um
when i look at the landscape of the nba
and i see all of the things that go on
with the um
you know guys teaming up to play with
each other now if shaquille o'neal
became a free agent and wanted to come
play with the 76ers i would have loved
you know to play with him or kobe bryant
um but i never thought about you know
going to
you know be would team up with other
guys um i never thought about that
because i always felt like
you know guys on my spot were good
enough because they they pros dan you
know what i mean like and i always used
to think you know about
myself and the belief that i had myself
and i thought oh damn if you put me with
four other professionals on the
basketball court then we can't be beat
you know what i'm saying and and
i used to always like the best feeling
that i had as a basketball player um
throughout my career was the fact that
my teammates felt like um if they had me
in the foxhole was
with them that we would have a chance to
win against anybody and i feel like
that's how y'all teammates feel about
him you know as long as we got him we
could win but could you have changed
your style to preserve your like have a
little bit more longevity because you
attacked
and right and at some point like dwayne
wade attacked and then stopped attacking
as much michael jordan stopped attacking
him could you have changed and do you do
you think
josh should be concerned about that
attacking all the time
i don't i don't i think um
you know if he tried to alter his game
he wouldn't be him he wouldn't be the
guy that he is today
and um
you know i i don't have
um
too many regrets i think probably the
only regret that i have
in my careers
um is that i didn't listen to coach
brown earlier you know what i mean if i
if i was able to take constructive
criticism a lot better and understood
that it was constructive criticism and
not him just getting on me just because
he wanted the same thing that i wanted
you know what i mean and that was to win
and if i would have let him polish me um
a lot earlier i think uh it would have
made me better and it would have made us
better
um and one more thing i i think
me being um someone that didn't like to
lift weights
um
i kind of regret that because i i think
how much better could i have been
if i would have been a lot stronger you
know what i mean um
i remember a time with billy king we had
a new strength and um conditioning coach
and billy king introduced me to him and
i was like you know why would you
we're not gonna have a good we're not
gonna have any type of relationship
you know i didn't i didn't like to lift
weights because i thought they were too
heavy
but looking back on it like but you
didn't like to practice either though
alan i mean that was that was that was
that was such that was so off
and that was that was
something that that bothered me a lot
because um
i think
uh
the way kids look up to me
um
and the way guys even even guys in the
league look up to me
i didn't never want them to think that
that wasn't important and and that
wasn't the message that i was sending
you know what i mean it was just that um
that press conference and they just kept
asking me about the same thing and i got
fed up and it was just one of those days
that um i didn't want to
you know i didn't want to talk about
that i was i was there the press
conference was to tell my fans in philly
that um i wasn't getting traded that was
that was you know what it was about i
just met with coach and billy king and
they kept asking me about practice and i
just i just got frustrated
it's still a great line by you though
yeah but it was just it was interpreted
yeah
you can't there's no way now now now if
if if people do think that i didn't like
the practice
and i didn't practice then damn how good
was that
problems the things that i've done
without practicing no way you should do
one of those nfts of that press
conference where you're saying we're
talking about practice
you can make some money off that very
lucrative yes it is
i was there game one when you played the
lakers in the finals
and he went off
and i'm thinking can philadelphia
win four games i didn't think you guys
could win four games against that talent
but what did you think would you have 48
against
i definitely i definitely thought i
definitely thought
that we could win um
when we won
game one i we had game two i think
derrick hit a big shot on me at the um
at the end
um i think i didn't get over a screen or
i was trying to help or something and he
hit a big shot but we had him again
adam and game two as well
um
but all in all they were a better team i
mean um
you know um
may rest in peace and god bless them you
know kobe bryant he didn't destroy us
you know what i mean um like he had in
the regular season uh shaquille o'neal
beat us and everybody talked about the
kimberly having a great series but shaq
averaged like 30 something in 15. yeah
and we we couldn't we tried and we
couldn't deal with them but all in all
only they were just a better team than
us they just you know they had the
talent obviously um
and you know they were just a better
team at the end of the day what's it
like standing next to shaq
you ever stood next to a tree
[Laughter]
a big tree
you know what i mean but that's a tree
that moves ai that moves
and and we'll run into you
not a stationary tree that you have to
run into now that will ruin to you
but i i i'll be around them now and and
and
it amazes me like i used to actually go
in here and
have him contest my shots like i must
have been out of my mind
that aggressive you know what i mean to
go in there with him in it
if you could give me one season right
now would you play for the nets or the
lakers
you had to pick between those two
the next in the lakers with the squad
they have right now yeah
um
i don't let me
see was kyrie kyrie was considered a um
a two guard this year right
yeah
he was considered a two yeah
i would rather whatever team that i
could have played it too
wasn't me i think with the lakers russ
obviously would have been um
he would have been the point it would
have been the point and then i i could
be off the ball and i could guard the
point guard he could guard two guard
being how big he is and then lebron
could have played the three so i think i
would probably fit better with the
lakers you know being it
you know kyrie is being as great as he
is um
and now we would have just been too
small of a backcourt to try to match up
with people
could lebron ever surpass michael jordan
as the best player in your opinion i
would i would i would never
i'll never put anybody before him i mean
you know obviously for you know personal
reasons um
because
you know
what he means so much to me and what he
meant so much to me in my life and my
career
um
and then i just think you know he's the
greatest player to ever play um i think
lebron james is the greatest
all-around player
you know that ever played the game i
mean he's definitely on the mount
rushmore basketball um
you know but definitely you know him
lebron
um well mike
uh
kobe lebron
shaquille
and steph are definitely my all-time
favorite
it's great to talk to you hope you're
doing well could you could you play 10
minutes a night i like if somebody
needed you tonight could you play 10
no i i probably can go i probably can
play 10 minutes but then i have to be in
one minute stretch
i know
i'm 46 years old and in june i'll be 47
so i don't even think about that and why
get tired shooting jump shots now man uh
good luck as uh the brand ambassador
there for points bet and great to catch
up with you again thank you thank you
man thank you man big fan and uh thanks
for having me man i appreciate you